is it's easy to get to CS if you've
never played a tactical shooter before
people got into CS no problem for 20
years and then valorent came out
and the entire world of of gaming and
FPS was just like oh CS so hard brain
too small cannot fathom how difficult
maybe it's a little bit of a hot take
but I do think that on some level the
FPS Community just like willfully dumbed
themselves down after the release of
valorant Counter-Strike isn't that hard
to get into and I think people make it
out to be this like Ultra intimidating
thing that is like oh it's way too much
for me you know I mean like I'll never
be able to understand all those fans of
smoke grenades and how the spray
patterns were I just don't think it's
like this thing that is like so
intimidating that it like baffles the
Mortal intellect
people have been getting into CS go no
problem since like 2013 right like I
don't know why that all changed in 2020.